- Ich bin die Astrid Kuth.
Ich bin hier die Küchenchefin und die
Inhaberin im Restaurant Strandhaus.
- Mein Name ist Günter Grote-Vallée
und ich arbeite als Restaurantleiter
hier im Restaurant Strandhaus.
- Der Gast steht hier immer im
Mittelpunkt. Und das ist halt wichtig,
dass die Leute zum Gast
einfach offen und freundlich sind.
- Es kommt natürlich auch sehr,
sehr viel Fachwissen noch dazu.
- Ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag
im Restaurant beginnt:
Restaurantfachmann Günter
kümmert sich um den Gästeraum.
In der Küche haben die Vorbereitungen
für das Essen angefangen:
Das Gemüse wird geputzt
und geschnitten.
Die Kartoffeln werden geschält.
Es wird gekocht und gebraten.
Beim Personalessen bespricht das Team,
was für diesen Tag wichtig ist.
Günter und Astrid sprechen
über weitere Details.
Die ersten Gäste kommen
und werden von Günter begrüßt.
Zuerst gibt es etwas zu trinken,
während in der Küche
schon das Essen zubereitet wird.
Günter serviert das Essen
und wünscht den Gästen guten Appetit.
Mehr über den Beruf des
Restaurantfachmanns
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.